- Global climate change is
wreaking havoc on this planet.
In the Pacific, many islands
are projected to disappear
like Atlantis.
In the Arctic, polar ice caps are melting,
in Australia, devastating brush fires
have killed 3 billion animals,
and in America, we're getting
once in a century storms
twice a decade.
And like with most things,
it's up to the lawyers
to save the day.
Because whether the world acts
to mitigate the effects of climate change
depends a lot on the state of the law
in the world's most developed nations.
And when the law has to change,
who are you gonna call?
Lawyers.
(light melodic music)
- [Announcer] Brought to you
in partnership with Bill Gates.
- Hey, Legal Eagles.
It's time to think like, well, a lawyer.
Because like it or not, the
lawyers are going to have a role
in fighting climate change,
because climate change
is a global problem,
which demands global solutions.
And often emissions that
are made in one area
affects another place in the world,
if not the world at large.
So to really impact the
temperature of the world,
nations have to act in concert
over the long-term for decades.
However, the ability of the
world to tackle climate change
depends substantially
on how sovereign nations
are constrained by their
own form of government
and especially their laws.
And not all countries view
climate change the same way.
Denmark for instance, passed a law
that made climate change actually illegal.
And now every year, the Danish government
will need to find a majority
parliamentary approval
of its global and national
climate strategies.
The law commits Denmark to
making all major policy decisions
through a green lens to assess
their impact on climate.
And the country has to
share green technologies
with other nations so that
they can reduce emissions.
Eight of the 10 parties
in the Danish parliament
voted for the law which limits
how much future governments
can undermine it.
But what's possible in Denmark
might not be possible in the U.S.
And right now the United States
is not exactly known for
passing bipartisan legislation.
So America's strategy may
be more, well, American.
Because in America, we
just sue each other.
So, if you're climate mindful
you probably wonder how
individuals might be able
to pressure the government
to act through lawsuits.
And naturally many people have attempted
to sue fossil fuel
companies for the emissions
that are a by-product of those products.
And lawsuits in Europe have
had some success in this area.
Particularly last March, a
U.K. court of appeals said
that plans to expand Heathrow
Airport were unlawful
because they failed to take
the Paris Climate Agreement
into account.
But in America, climate change plaintiffs
have yet to find big
success in federal court.
The first major hurdle
for American litigants
is whether cases can satisfy
the threshold procedural requirements
for a court to even decide a case.
These include concepts like standing,
which examines whether
litigants are the right parties
to bring a lawsuit.
Most recent cases brought
by American citizens
have been knocked out at these
early stages of litigation.
For example, a 2018 case
brought by Oregon children
initially satisfied a motion to dismiss,
but the ninth circuit
court of appeals reversed.
The child plaintiffs asserted
that they had a fifth amendment
right to a climate system
capable of sustaining human life,
but the ninth circuit said
that the kids lack standing
to bring the claims.
The court rejected the premise
that courts should decide
climate change issues
saying that only the legislative
and executive branches of
government have that power.
And this isn't terribly surprising.
American courts aren't
supposed to set policy.
So many U.S. courts have
dismissed lawsuits on the basis
that courts simply
can't set a policy where
the executive branch has been
given authority to regulate.
And that was one of the issues
in the first Supreme court case
to decide whether
corporations could be sued
for greenhouse gas emissions.
American Electric versus Connecticut.
The lawsuit was filed by
eight States, New York City,
in three land conservation
groups against the TVA
the Tennessee Valley Authority,
as well as several other power companies.
The plaintiff's alleged
that the defendants
were a public nuisance
because their CO2 emissions
contributed substantially
to global warming.
The Supreme Court held that
only the Environment
Protection Agency, the EPA,
could set emission standards
and that the EPA's authority
prevented plaintiffs
from suing under a legal theory
based on federal common law, nuisance law.
And based on the EPA's
designated authority,
it's up to the EPA to decide whether
and how to regulate
greenhouse gas emissions
from the defendant power plants.
States and cities don't have the right
to sue the utility companies.
In 2021, the Supreme Court will decide
a major climate change case,
but only on the narrow technical issues
about whether the case must
be removed from state court
to federal court.
The city of Baltimore
filed the lawsuit in 2018
against oil and gas companies
saying that their products
had dangerous impacts on climate
injuring Baltimore citizens.
And defendants filed a
motion to remove the case
to federal court.
Now, the fourth circuit
eventually decided the case
should remain in state court.
Defendants petition the
Supreme court for review
because the circuit courts
differ on the federal grounds
for removal and whether the
state courts needed to review
every ground for removal.
And right now your eyes may
be glazing over with boredom
since this seems like a side skirmish
in a much bigger battle.
And while this is
definitely a technical issue
at the same time
the court's ruling will
certainly impact the speed
at which climate change
cases are reviewed.
But it's also possible the
Supreme Court may express
down about the judiciary's rule
in deciding climate change cases.
The Supreme court doesn't
like to decide things,
it doesn't absolutely have to.
And this would mean punting
on the substantive issue
so that America's
extremely high-functioning,
very efficient Senate and
House of Representatives
could pass beautiful legislation.
- I have a feeling it's
going to be beautiful.
- And even if plaintiffs survive
early motions to dismiss,
liability determinations are
very complicated to sort out.
How much fault can you attribute
to one particular defendant?
What happens when all of the
emissions are commingled?
and how do you divvy out the damages
amongst the entire world?
And plaintiffs would have to show
that the defendant's created actual harm
and damages the plaintiffs.
This involves a battle of experts
and real questions about remedies.
And while European litigants
have been successful
in changing actual policy,
the difficulty of determining a remedy
has been prompted many
American courts to question
whether the judicial branch
is really the right forum
for these disputes.
Now, at this point, the question
you're probably asking is,
well, what about international law then?
Well, there's a reason that the U.S.
generally doesn't like to play nice
under international rules.
But international law is
increasingly playing a major role
on climate disputes with good reason.
For example smaller island nations
are in an especially precarious position.
The intergovernmental
panel on climate change
reported in 2014 that one
meter of sea level rise
would wipe out 15% of Pacific islands.
And that means the destruction
of many people's homes
and entire cultures.
For example, Tuvalu,
an Island of approximately 10,000 people
has a high point of only
13 feet above sea level.
Their citizens claim that the actions
of the world's industrialized nations
are slowly flooding the island.
Tuvalu is arguing that some
nations owe them compensation.
And although industrialized nations
make up only 20% of
the world's population,
they account for 60% of the
annual carbon dioxide emissions.
and America is responsible for 25%
of all global greenhouse gas
emissions all on its own.
♪ America ♪
So Tuvalu is threatening to
sue the U.S. and Australia
since both are not signatories
to the Kyoto Protocol,
the climate change treaty
that requires lower
greenhouse gas emissions
from industrialized nations.
Now, a claim like that
might conceivably be brought
in the United Nations
International Court of Justice.
Every country that is a member of the U.N.
is a member of the court,
but not all countries
accept its jurisdiction.
The ICJ has two kinds of jurisdiction.
First, the court has
jurisdiction over disputes
between states that have
accepted the jurisdiction
of the court.
There are 74 governments that
accept the ICJ's jurisdiction,
but the U.S. is not one of them.
However, if Tuvalu
wanted to bring a lawsuit
against the country that
was part of the ICJ,
it probably could.
The ICJ decides cases using
international conventions
and customs.
Its decisions, however, generally
don't apply as precedent.
And on top of that, the court's decision
binds only the parties
to that particular case
in controversy.
And the ICJ's second type of jurisdiction
is the ability to give advisory opinions.
The U.N. General Assembly
or the Security Council
may request an opinion from the ICJ.
These opinions would not be binding
but they can influence public policy.
Many Pacific islands are now
pushing for an advisory opinion
on climate change through the ICJ
but even if they were successful
that would be a nonbinding decision.
So international lawsuits
are not likely to have a huge effect
on U.S. policy as it stands.
So the bottom line is
that the lawyers are
trying to save the day
but those pesky judges and courts
just keep getting in the way,
which means that we're
going to have to turn to,
and I hate to say it, the politicians.
We're going to have to
adopt some new laws.
And not only that, but some of the laws
that we've already adopted
are frankly counterproductive.
So the question is, what
laws should America pursue?
Well, first we can turn to
some global success stories
regarding greenhouse gas emissions.
For example, Norway has
aggressively targeted gasoline
and diesel burning cars,
creating incentives for electric vehicles.
Electric cars now account for
about half of all vehicles
in Norway,
which you would know if you've ever seen
a GM ad featuring Will Ferrell.
- No way, no way, knock,
knock, it's America.
And we're gonna punch you in the face.
- Now every major automotive
manufacturer in the world
is developing fleets of plug-in vehicles.
American lawmakers can create
incentives for electric cars.
The European Union banned
the use of hydrofluorocarbons
which are greenhouse gases
used in air conditioners
and refrigerators.
The U.S. can and has in the
past taken similar action.
British Columbia adopted a carbon tax.
It has caused emissions to fall.
And there have been in the past
times when American citizens
were willing to pay so called sin taxes,
taxes on booze and cigarettes
in order to finance things
like sports stadiums.
Canada and the U.S. agreed in 2016
to curve methane emissions
from oil and gas operations.
The Trump administration rolled
back a lot of those efforts
but it's possible that
the Biden administration
could unroll back those
efforts if they wanted to.
And while there have been
global success stories
there have also been some local
state based success stories
as well here in the United States.
For example, California
has been leading the way
on energy efficient building
standards since the 1970s.
The state standards
continue to get stricter
as new technologies arrive on the scene.
And if these standards were adopted
throughout the United States,
it would impact emissions
for heating and cooling
on a nation wide basis.
States like New York and California
already require utilities
to produce their electricity
from zero carbon sources.
That means it's solar, wind, water,
and potentially nuclear
power are more enticing.
If the rest of the nation followed suit
it could mean a huge
reduction in CO2 emissions.
And the New York Times estimates
that if the U.S. adopted these policies,
it would quote, slash
greenhouse gas emissions
in United States by roughly
29% below 2005 levels
by 2025 and roughly 50% by 2050.
And then there are some more controversial
but potentially even more
efficacious policies available
like cap and trade, which
allows individuals more choice
over how they reduce emissions.
Now cap and trade as
most people envision it
is a different method
than the typical command
and control approach
where the government just simply
sets performance standards
or forces consumers to pick
electric vehicles for instance.
Cap and trade allows the market
to determine the price on carbon,
and the price drives investment decisions
and spurs market innovation.
Is this a tax?
Well, cap and trade differs from tax
in that it provides a
high level of certainty
about future emissions
but not about the price
of those emissions,
which leads to a question
about the constitutionality
of a cap and trade policy
because the policy is only as good as
whether it is constitutional
in the first place
to be implemented.
So while some have questioned
whether a federal cap and trade program
would be constitutional
because of the limits of the
constitution's Commerce Clause,
some states have had a
cap and trade program
for a pretty long time.
For example, California,
which has had a cap and
trade program for many years
and has an agreement with Quebec
through a cross-linked border market,
the regulated actors in
the two jurisdictions
were able to trade their
allocated admissions allowances.
But the state's program was challenged
by the Trump administration
which basically claimed
that California couldn't
engage in foreign policy,
that that was reserved solely
for the federal government.
But so far, California has been successful
at the federal trial level and
has been allowed to continue
with its particular agreement.
And then there's the
possibility of truly local
or state based measures
or potentially even a federal framework
to eliminate zoning restrictions
or softens zoning restrictions
to allow for greater
density in city centers.
Because as it happens,
individuals who live in big dense cities
tend to produce far less waste
and produce far fewer
greenhouse gas emissions.
And there are many reasons for it.
Number one, if you live in a big city
that allows you to walk
around or has public transit
then you're probably not going
to be polluting via a car.
And you're probably living in a building
that while on an absolute level
is producing more emissions,
when you divide it by the
sheer number of people
that are living in it,
it actually produces far
less on a per person basis.
So the cities tend to
be on a per person basis
far more efficient than the suburbs
and the rural areas as well.
And of course, not everyone
wants to move into a big density
and that's perfectly fine too.
No one needs to force anyone to do it,
but the truth is a lot
more people want to move
into these big, more efficient cities
but currently can't because
it's either too expensive
or there's not enough housing or both.
And a lot of that is
spurned by the actual laws
that are currently on the books.
Things like zoning
that currently limit the
amount of infill development
that could house more
people more efficiently,
all the people that want
to move into those cities.
But let me get down from my soap box.
This video is not intended to be a survey
of every possible solution
that's out there, far from it.
There's a lot more that
lawyers and normal people
can actually do to help
prevent climate change.
Really, the idea was
just to spark inspiration
in other professionals who
you might not assume have a role to play,
but if even the lawyers can get involved
then I guarantee other people can as well.
And this video was created in
partnership with Bill Gates,
and inspired by his new book,
"How to Avoid a Climate Disaster"
You can find out more about
how we can all work together
to avoid a climate disaster
using the link below.
(light melodic music)